-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers,
This is "Late Night."
We hope everybody's doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Hunter Biden spoke outside
the US Capitol yesterday
and criticized Republicans
for ridiculing
his struggle with addiction.
Unfortunately, when it
comes to Hunter Biden,
Republicans are also
struggling with addiction.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. Hunter Biden
spoke to reporters yesterday
and said that his father was
"not financially involved in
any of his business ventures."
Well, I believe that.
He seems like the kind of dad
who wouldn't even get involved
in your lemonade stand
when you were a kid.
[ As Biden ] "You want
to sell lemonade, do you?
I guess you'd better get busy
planting a lemon tree."
[ Laughter ]
At a rally last night in Iowa,
former President Trump said
that he feels mentally sharper
now than he was 20 years ago,
and added he is
a "much better golfer
than he was 10
or 15 years ago."
Well, that's what four years
of uninterrupted practice
will do for you.
[ Laughter ]
A new poll now shows
former President Trump
leading President Biden
in all seven swing states
that will decide
the 2024 election.
Which brings us
to our new segment,
"Seth Tries to Remember
Where He Put His Passport."
♪♪
Is it my desk drawer?
No, I took it out of my
desk drawer
'cause of the kids.
Maybe in my bag?
[ Laughter ]
Damn it. You know what?
I'm just going to...
"Call Alexi after show."
[ Laughter ]
-This has been...
"Seth Tries to Remember
Where He Put His Passport."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Russian President
Vladimir Putin
held his annual end-of-year
news conference today
and answered questions
for more than four hours --
important questions such as
"why are you so handsome"
and "please be
our president forever?"
[ Laughter ]
Today was former
House Speaker Kevin McCarthy's
last day at the Capitol
before he resigns
at the end of the year
from Congress.
There was a going away party
for him, but he wasn't invited.
[ Laughter ]
Boston Mayor Michelle Wu
is facing criticism
for holding a holiday party
specifically
for nonwhite members
of city council.
Said Wu, "Sorry if for once
I wanted the food to be good."
[ Laughter ]
According to the latest numbers,
North Dakota has
the lowest divorce rate
in the country
at less than 1%,
which is ironic since it's one
of the only states
that's legally separated
from its partner.
[ Laughter ]
Map comedy.
A family aboard their houseboat
in Florida
recently found a snake that
was hiding in a sock drawer.
Though, honestly,
on a houseboat in Florida,
I would have been more surprised
if they had found socks.
[ Laughter ]
I love that joke so much.
True story --
Did it yesterday,
stumbled on it a little bit.
Said to Baze, I said, "You know
what, Baze? Let's cut it.
Let's put it in tomorrow,
get the home run it deserves."
[ Laughter ]
Said it perfectly,
exact same result.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Apple is reportedly
planning to overhaul
its lineup of iPads
to make it
"less confusing for consumers."
In the meantime,
owners of an iPad
are being asked to direct
any tech questions they may have
to the nearest toddler.
[ Chuckles ]
That was a monologue, everybody!
We're off.
We're off and running.